there are thousands of women and girls
known as Calle working in the markets of
Ghana's capital Accra transporting wears
on their head they carry up to 40 kilos
at a time they come from rural families
in the north of the country effectively
migrants in their own land Zen I EBU
tells us she's 17 years old and has
three children she comes from Walla
Walla in the north she earns 20 sadies a
day around five euros for herself and
her children we travel to the north of
the country this is where the sahelian
zone begins a belt between the sahara
desert and the savanna to the south
there is some farming but very little
rain
in the village of tsavo loogu a theater
group is about to perform many people
from this region would love to go to
Europe the theatre group has taken up
the issue Amina mukha ella was once a
refugee himself he tells of his
experiences in the desert and trying to
cross the Mediterranean believe me if
you make it across the desert he says
then the story begins one family has a
son who's earning well abroad his father
can buy a tractor then another man comes
on the father of another family he's
envious and wants a tractor too so he
sends his daughter and two sons to
Europe preparations for the journey
begin they pay a so-called connecting
man who promises safe passage to Libya
the journey begins one of their friends
dies of thirst on the way and they bury
him in the Sahara amita michaela founded
the african development organization for
migration or AF do em for short the
group tours the villages and produces
radio clips they also teach in schools
on the dangers of trying to get to
Europe the play continues the sister
gets raped by a trafficker and dies the
brothers feel guilty for not protecting
her the oldest son eventually returns
home his sister is dead his brother
drowned in the Mediterranean the parents
are shocked and grieved the Sun cannot
bear to live with the guilt and sense of
failure
the regional capital tamale has become a
hub for migration amino Michaela meets
refugees here all the time
many of those people migrating are from
the ruler places become they come to
tumuli as a transit point arrange
themselves and then they do a ftom has
an office in tomorrow most of the
workers are former refugees Ibrahim
wampie knee broke off his journey in the
desert in Mali he knows many similar
cases uncountable their modern number
lose I knew not not even what a hundred
and I even knew some wine there now in
Europe a and you are not finding it easy
some of them even want to I mean just to
get fair and come back home and it's a
problem to them Amina mocha allah has
written an account of his own story he
says crossing the desert was the worst
the traffickers charged 140 euros per
person taking twenty eight thousand
euros in all more than 200 people in the
car so at a point in time people
suffocate to death if you suffocate just
because they overloaded nature of the
vehicle people suffocate to death that's
one thing and sometimes when you are
going and you your car breaks up on the
way that's a sign another serious
problem people ends up dying on the
route you know it's a few women in our
car there were six some from Nigeria and
then some from Ghana this is a point and
a place where they will just call them
send them to their house and be ripping
them what we are we waiting for them to
go at that point if you try to misbehave
they ask you to lie down face the Sun
imagine on the desert amino mocha Allah
tried three times to cross to Italy
twice the boat capsized and he ended up
back in Libya on his third attempt he
was rescued by a ship from the German
charity cop on amor and taken to Italy
together with other refugees from Ghana
but they were immediately deported Amina
muka Allah comes from a farming family
his father was unable to support him he
takes us to the village of goo bula he
grew thanks to a new irrigation system
local residents are escaping subsistence
farming now they can even harvest crops
twice a year the mighty several mama now
I harvest 35 sacks of rice per hectare I
used to get just five but we need
tractors if we want to expand the area
we farm then we wouldn't have so many
people leaving like our girls who go to
Accra to carry market where's some of my
family have already gone mad at America
come on to a corner a Reservoir Dam has
turned the Savannah into an oasis the
rice and vegetable plantations here
sponsored by European aid are exemplary
amino and AF do em want to initiate more
projects like this so we want to see how
best as much as we are campaigning 00
still campaigning against or convincing
them not to go we should also have an
alternative for them to stay in Ghana
here maybe initiatives like those
organised by AF do em will encourage
more people to stay providing a decent
future for them here in their homeland
so they don't attempt the dangerous
journey to Europe
you